When we use the right frequency every night, do we get any benefits for our lymphatic system?
Well, I do put lymphatic drainage programs in everybody's overnight program,
but, you know, I don't, everybody responds to frequencies differently, so everybody has also
a lymphatic program on their right, both those that would have the trough and those that have
the atelier, but you can run those also. There's swelling programs that you can run.
There's inflammation programs that you can run. Those all have very similar frequencies
that are aimed at trying to decrease inflammation. Again, when somebody comes to you with cancer,
the majority of the frequencies in their overnight program are going to be cancer.
So, the reason why I put all those other programs on there is that if you have other symptoms,
you can run those. So, I would run some of those programs that I just mentioned separately during
the day, or liggy read or something, to help with if you have lymphatic issues, or if you have
lymphub, my swelling, or something like that.